Seating can be a beautiful rest of a busy day
But as many of us spend most of the time working on an office
Followed by free time in front of a computer or TV
One has to wonder,
How does sitting affect your body?
The answer is very shocking
Once seated, the electrical activity in your muscles decreases significantly
Your calorie burning rate is reduced to one minute per minute
After only 3 hours of sitting, there is a 50% reduction in the widening of the arteries
Resulting in a decrease in blood flow
Sit for 24 hours continuously, and your insulin will lose 40% of its ability to absorb glucose
Which increases the likelihood of developing type 2 diabetes
Things get worse here
After two weeks of sitting for more than 6 hours a day
Low-density lipoproteins (LDL), sometimes called LDL cholesterol, increase.
With many fatty molecules, puts you at risk of gaining weight.
Above all this, the enzyme responsible for lipid analysis, drops.
Because of a long period of inactivity, your muscles begin to collapse.
Gradually, the contraction of your muscles weakens, ending by blocking the return of blood to the heart.
Even if you practice regularly,
The moment you stop moving, the breakdown starts again, proportioning to your sitting time.
This scary part,
Research shows that exercise alone does not frustrate the negative effects of something like smoking,
The negative effects of long sitting are not discouraged
After a year, the ether begins to accumulate
Some studies on women showed a reduction in bone mass of more than 1% each year
Do you think your mind is more important than your body?
Physical movement not only helps pump blood and oxygen into the brain, but also sends hormones to improve mood.
When we do not move, brain functions begin to slow down.
Perhaps the most shocking, that after 10-20 years of sitting for 6 hours a day,
May lose more than 7 years of "quality-adjusted years"
The number of years it has been without medical problems or death
For example, the risk of death from heart disease increases 64%
While the risk of prostate cancer or breast cancer increases 30%
If everyone sat for no more than 3 hours a day, it is estimated that the average age will increase by two years.
Simply put, our bodies were not designed to stagnate.
Sitting for 8 hours while working is as bad as sitting at home watching television
As far as those who go to the gyms
It can literally be deadly.
So what's the best solution?
We put together a list of the best tips to fight the B-sit, no matter how lazy you are,
Using scientific research and smart tips to make it easy.
There is a link in the description of that section, you should see it absolutely!
Special thanks to Audible.com for supporting this episode
And provide free audio books when you choose audible.com/asap
Audible is the leading provider of audio books with over 150,000 titles available for download in various types of literature.
We are the author of Richard Dawkins's The Selfish Gene
Which contains some amazing ideas about evolution and the biological world.
You can download this audio book or other for free by audible.com/asap
By signing up you can get one free book every month!
Special thanks for audible to make this section possible!
Subscribe to more scientific videos every week!